[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
vice president kamala harris and second
gentleman doug emhoff last week became
the first known second family to host a
passover seder at their residence or as
fox news called it tonight's top story
an unnamed worker has filed a labor
complaint claiming that nintendo
violated their right to unionize even
worse their boss showed up to work
wearing just a tie
barrel
terry yeah you have to play super smash
brothers
who do you pick luigi
the correct answer is donkey kong
sorry all right all right well can't
wait to beat you you have your opinion
and i have luigi
ladies and gentlemen our first fight
a kindergarten student in michigan
recently brought a bottle of margarita
mix to school and shared it with four
classmates
luckily they had a designated driver
fine
let children drink an online
an online pharmacy recently used google
data from 86 countries to publish a list
of the nations with the largest penis
size which is why you should always read
those pop-ups before saying yes
[Music]
[Applause]
don't let them do it don't
a massachusetts woman with a learner's
permit practiced her driving last
weekend in a cemetery and crashed into
eight graves
the victims were pronounced dead on
arrival
yes yeah yeah that was great yeah
are we friends again yeah we're great
okay
marvel studios this week released a
trailer for the upcoming film thor love
and thunder but only because they're too
chicken to make the movie everybody
really wants thor loving basketball
oh you would watch the butt off of that
yeah you know there's a marvel on
another marvel one with the punisher
called love bones
that is only for black people that get
love jones
get marvel it's a very small niche of
black people
i love bones oh my god you guys after i
do this show for you tarik then does an
even more specific show just for me
and finally according to reports south
korea may change the way they count
citizens ages making millions of people
a year younger i'm listening said
leonardo dicaprio
and that was a monologue did you like
the monologue
great
another 200 satisfied customers
moving on comedian ally wong announced
last week that she and her husband
justin hakuta are separating but when
reporting on the story some media
outlets used the wrong photo instead of
a photo of justin hakuta many used a
photo of actor randall park
yes they did and we here at the amber
ruffin show are tired of seeing this
kind of mix-up it happens to minorities
too often and is brushed aside as a
little mistake well we would never make
a mistake like that so we are asking all
media outlets to take more care when
reporting on minorities how would you
feel if we accidentally mixed up white
people do better okay
in other news
a new book has been released that
reveals that mitch mcconnell chose to
remain quiet during donald trump's
stolen election plans because he was
scared
mitch mcconnell feared that if he spoke
out against the attempted steal donald
trump would interfere in the election
campaigns of republicans david perdue
and kelly leckler
now
all of this caused trump supporters to
feel like they have the right to storm
the capital when asked if he's finally
going to stand up to trump for the good
of the country mitch mcconnell had this
to say
i'll just have to pay a visit to that
blubber-headed hound and gently break
him in two with my good right arm
typical well if mcconnell doesn't want
to defend democracy maybe it's time he
quits and goes back to his old job
hosting asmr videos
so in conclusion we wish ali wong the
best and mitch mcconnell can go jump in
a lake
in more serious news three mass
shootings took place in america this
past weekend and they came just one week
after the shooting in brooklyn now every
time something like this happens
americans ask the same question will
congress finally introduce a meaningful
gun control bill well last night i saw a
commercial for two lawmakers who are
trying to do just that take a look
hello i'm dan davenport and i'm carol
kerrigan and we are united states
congress people over and over again
americans are subjected to acts of gun
violence but no one in congress ever
seems to do anything about it that's why
this week we're coming together to
introduce bill h.r 321 a bill that will
require all guns in the u.s to be
imprinted with the phrase hey be careful
now
that's right if our bill is passed into
law every gun will in the nation will
have the phrase hey be careful now print
it right on it it could be on the butt
of the gun or on the scope or on the
shooty part
i don't really know the names of the
parts of a gun even though i own 30 of
them
the point is we take gun control
seriously we're doing something about it
and that thing we're willing to do is
make sure every gun is emblazoned with
the phrase hey be careful now
we know what you're thinking couldn't
you ban assault rifles instead or close
gun show loopholes or ban gun ownership
for people convicted of domestic
violence
no
but what we can do is put the phrase hey
be careful now on every gun and we can
do it in all caps so people take us
seriously
when we turned on the news last week and
saw one gun related tragedy after
another we knew we had to do something
so we consulted the experts we said what
can we do to reduce gun violence
they gave us a bunch of suggestions and
we ignored them all
and we wrote this bill instead
but this bill won't pass without your
support so if you care about america or
more importantly if you care about
seeming like you care about america
then call your congressperson today and
ask them to vote yes on h.r 321
h.r 321 because nothing stronger has any
chance of passing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you